now we like a bit of VR here on Sunrise
virtual reality explain get with a
program Gillian we feature it regularly
on swipe of course it's being adapted
and used for so many different sort of
things gaming education healthcare
military we had a great thing with
military VR couple months ago but now
it's being adapted for gambling as well
Jo Morris has got all the answers ahead
of swipe tonight Gemma or interactive
interactive gaming s that might also
have some marks of course yes this week
we have been looking at this gambling
industry and I gaming interactive
gambling and is virtual reality helping
increase that thrill that rush involved
in gambling and you can get casinos a
casino experience with a virtual reality
headset which Sony's very familiar with
although you're not quite convinced
about its positives just yet I feel
convinced about the positives I think
that it's probably slightly early stage
in terms of its uses and and whether
it's sort of funky enough for the
players to to be attracted to it a bit
and at the moment but I think I mean
we're having a look at the lucky VR
application here and you know they've
done a great job in terms of not give
you are specifically designed for
virtual reality software for casinos yes
that's right honestly I mean it looks
beautiful it works you've got all the
popular game so to the games you're
seeing here are already popular games so
they are creating the experience that
the player wants in terms of the content
and here this is quite an interesting
one because you get a big screen effect
on a game but you know in terms of how
useful it is at the moment you know this
Hardware issues in terms of how much it
costs and those sorts of things so how
many people do we know that have Tony
how does it to the real-life experience
of going to a casino because I mean
they're not but I do go to casinos but I
guess that's the appeal for people
actually being in there in the
atmosphere and you know pulling those
yeah I'm saying nothing's I don't think
anything is ever going to replace
sitting in a casino you know you can
have a drink in there you can genuinely
socialise with people so I think that
this is going to replace that I think
for when it's very dark and it's very
cold in your at home and you want to get
as much of a thrill as possible from
gambling you know quick fix so obviously
with the advent of mobiles and tablets
in terms of gaming people are now
spending far less time actually doing it
that they have for quick access so it's
not really to replace that and what
you're seeing here with virtual reality
is also using an attempt to get as close
as possible to make you feel like you
are on that table have a good feel at
gambling how'd it go on a horse
pretend horse in the race this is the
development from one bookmaker whereby
you can actually place a bit on horse
and then you've got your headset on and
you're on the horse that you fact quite
uncomfortable because it was really wide
and it's made of plastic so here we are
love them and we should actually have
some images of what I can see in my
headset so I'm on the horse and this
this is actually linked up to real races
so Kempton Park will be having a real
race this is a prototype at the moment
you back your horse and you're on your
horse all the way through the race a
downside was actually that I came last
though all right I mean it was a fun
experience but not if you're back I can
see that it's good because obviously a
lot of people are to put a few quid on
the horses and actually if you can if
you tooth happen and not just be a
spectator but be the jockey I did ask if
they had faced much criticism you know
in terms of encouraging gambling at that
younger age obviously over 18 but at the
younger side of the spectrum and they
said no not yes but but Tony you think
you look about trailblazing really don't
you yeah and I think that's that's quite
an interesting point actually because
because this is also probably been seen
as a way to access a market of players
that don't currently go into casinos and
so the Millennials that we call
I'm sure it's a generic term everywhere
no those are the ones that are I say
they don't generally go into but make
the shops because those are students
slightly older welding and also they
won't go to a casino whereas you know I
would just enter gender for I think next
year you gonna see a lot of headset to
come out for VR it's gonna be you know
openness and yeah and there's so many
and they're they're going to become
affordable quite quickly and you can get
them now at 150 200 pounds and I think
at that stage you might see an entrance
into the market of a lot of players that
don't currently play yeah which is very
appealing to to the operators oh well
regulation I can see clipping of all
gambling lovely good to see each other
thank you swipe some night 9:30 tomorrow
2:30 and Sunday 8:30 p.m. I'll remember